بدات في تركيا صباح اليوم عمليات التصويت
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
يتنافس على منصب الرئاسه الرئيس التركي
ومرشح تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
ومرشح تحالف الشعب وزعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمال
ومرشح وتحالف الاجداد سنان اوغان وكان
مرشح حزب البلد محرم انجا قد قرر الانسحاب
من السباق الرئاسي يوم الخميس الماضي
يشارك في هذه الانتخابات نحو 60 مليون
ونصف مليون ناخب مسجلين على لوائح
الاقتراع انتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد لمده
خمس سنوات والاختيار اعضاء البرلمان
البالغ عددهم 600 نائب ويتنافسوا على
مقاعده 24 حزبا سياسيا
والصور التي تشاهدون الان صور مباشره من
اسطنبول في مركز من مراكز الاقتراع هناك
في بدايه التصويت في هذه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
نستطلع اجواء هذا التصويت مع مراسلين من
ازمير عمر الحاج ومن انقره المعتز بالله
حسن وابدا مع المعتز بالله حسن من انقره
كيف تسير عمليه التصويت في هذه الساعات
الاولى من الاقتراع
من الواضح ان هناك كثافه في عمليه التصويت
والاقبال على هذا التصويت منذ بدء فتح
صناديق الاقتراع قبل حوالي ساعه من الان
كان هناك اعداد
جيده جدا مقارنه مع الانتخابات السابقه في
بدايه هذه العمليه سيكون هناك ربما عبر
ساعات النهار المقبله تقدير لما اذا كانت
هذه الكثافه ستستمر ام لا نحن هنا في
واحده في واحد من مراكز الاقتراع هنا في
العاصمه انقره يمكن ان تشاهدون هناك كيف
ان الناس فعلا هي بدات
بالقدوم منذ ساعات الصباح والمشاركه هناك
اكثر من 60 مليون ناخب داخل تركيا ولا
ننسى انه كان هناك ايضا ثلاثه ملايين ونصف
ناخب خارج تركيا هناك حوالي خمسه ملايين
ناخب سيتمكنون من التصويت للمره الاولى
عدد مراكز الاقتراع في عموم تركيا
عفوا على الصناديق الاقتراع 1992 الف
صندوق ويشارك تقريبا 24 حزبا سياسيا في
هذه
الانتخابات وثلاثه مرشحين رئاسيين في هذا
المركز قبل قليل كنا قد شاهدنا وجود من
يسميهم الاتراك المراقبون مراقبون
الدوليون لعمليه الانتخاب وبالتالي هذه
العمليه الان هي تجري ايضا ضمن رقابه وجود
اعضاء من الرقابه الدوليه
والاقبال كما ذكرت يتوقع ان يستمر في
ساعات النهار المقبله لان هناك استقطابا
كبيرا كان قبل هذه الانتخابات
واجرائها اثناء الحملات الانتخابيه الصمت
الانتخابي كان بدا يوم امس في الساعه
السادسه مساء ولكن الان هناك اعداد جيده
جدا مقارنه مع الانتخابات بدايات
الانتخابات التي شاهدناها في السنوات
الماضيه وانت تتحدث المعتز بالله كنا
نشاهد عمليه الاقت في كذا محافظه في عموم
تركيا لكن نتوقف في ازمير ايضا مع عمر
الحاج ما خصوصيه الاقتراع هناك عمر
نعم مريم بدايه لا بد من الاشاره الى ان
الاعداد كبيره جدا في مراكز الاقتراع في
عمومي ازمير انا هنا في حي السن جاك وسط
المدينه اريد فقط ان اريكم طبيعه هذا
الازدحام ونحن نتحدث عن ساعه واحده في
مدينه من المعروف عنها ان من المدينه التي
يطيل اهلها السهر ان صح القول ولكن
المراكز ممتلئه في تغطيات سابقه
للانتخابات وصادف ان كنت هنا في اسمي هناك
سيما رئيسيه هنا في المدينه وهي ان كبار
السن حتى من
ربما من يصعب علي حتى المشي هم من اكثر
الفئات التي تسعى الى المشاركه في اي
استحقاق الانتخابي اريد فقط ان اريكم في
هذا الرواق اقتضاض الناس عن الساعه
التاسعه حتى تقريبا ساعه واحده فقط عن بدء
الاختراع وكما تشاهدون هذا المركز الذي
فيه اربع صناديق انتخابيه هنا حتى هنا
ثمان صناديق انتخابيه مكتس تماما
بالناخبين جئنا قبل الساعه الثامنه وكان
الناس ينتظرون في صفوف طويله هناك نوع من
ربما الاشتياق بنصح القول والدفاع للادلاء
بالاصوات في انتخابات كما قال كل الزملاء
انتخابات حساسه جدا في في مرحله حساسه تمر
بها تركيا وكما ذكرت هذا هذه عينه من كبار
السن الذين يحاولون الوصول الى صناديق
الاقتراع عموما في ازمير اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين ناخب المدينه فيها عشره الاف صندوق
من اصل 190 الف صندوق في المدينه المدينه
ولاؤها التقليدي لي الاحزاب العلمانيه
وتحديدا حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض وان
كانت حزب وكان الحزب العد
نسبه ايضا لا يستهان بها اخر انتخابات حقق
فيها الحزب نحو ثلاثه 38 بالمئه وكان
للرئيس اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
السابقه ايضا نصيب مشابه حاله من
الاستقطاب الكبير خاصه نتحدث عن
متسابقين بالتحديد المتسابقين الرئيسيين
او المرشحين الرئيسيين الرئيس اردوغان
اضافه
التي اعطتها كل استطلاعات الراي متقاربه
وكانهما
انتحاد هيا بالركب ان صح القول نسب كبيره
جدا وعلى هذا الاساس كلا الجانبين حث
افراد او من يؤيدوا افكاره وحزبه
بالمسارعه
للتصويت وكما رايتم عمليه التصويت هنا في
ازمير تمر بسلاسه حاله من الاكتضاض
والاقبال الشديد ونحن ما زلنا في الساعه
الاولى فقط من بدايه التصويت على هذه
الانتخابات
شكرا لك عمر